[Music]
can you please play d4 for once sure
let's play d4
we haven't done this in the speedrun but
i'll play d4 i'm not playing the london
that's the one caveat i'm gonna play c4
okay so dc
okay so this is the the queen's gamut
accepted now there is a myth
that a lot of people have
that the queen's game accepted is bad
for black
it's not bad for black it's actually one
of the main
weapons against one t4 it's considered
one of the most solid and reputable
lines
and white's got essentially two
approaches to the queen's gamut accepted
the first is to put the pawn on e3
and i will explain the pros and cons of
that
after the game the second is what we're
going to play right now this is
considered the sort of the most
ambitious line not necessarily the best
line but the most ambitious and that's
to play e4 black meets it with e5 that's
one of the main continuations and here
you just have to know theory
so here you have to know
that the move is knight f3 which is not
the easiest move to make if you don't
know the theory
now you can probably understand why de
is bad because it allows the queen trade
it gets the king out in the open that's
not the way we want to play this
now which one do we take well we didn't
give up the d4 pawn only to recapture it
and reopen
the standoff between the queens knight
takes d4 is very awkward
i'll explain all of the theoretical
things after the game folks so save your
save your questions on theory i don't
have the time to talk about it in depth
right now okay now bishop takes c4 so
this is a
we've turned this again into a gamma
we've sacrificed the pawn
but if black doesn't know exactly what
to do
um black gets in a lot of trouble
the valeri already making a mistake with
bishop g4 and this is a mistake for
several reasons i think
queen b3 is the obvious move hitting
both f7 and b so what else exists
we also have a tactic here
that you guys at this point should be
incredibly attuned to because we've had
it so many times bishop takes f7
king f7 and then not knight g5 right not
knight g5 there because if queen takes
g5 i've explained that trick before in a
speed run
but knight e5 because the knight there
cannot be captured not or knight e5
knight e5
so queen b3 looks amazing
bishop takes f7 looks amazing
i actually have a hard time deciding
here between these two moves i feel like
queen b3 might lead to a quick checkmate
though
i can't decide let me think
both options are so good
that it's hard to decide
i feel like queen b3 is actually more
promising because it threatens f7 i just
don't see a good defense to this move
i feel like this is even more ambitious
than bishop takes f7 check
yeah bishop f7 is a fun move to play but
okay we've played it a million times
before just making a move because it's a
temporary sacrifice isn't a good reason
to play it
this i feel like
is likelier to lead to a quick quick
knockout
if black is not super accurate
maybe bishop f7 was better who knows
i'm hoping that
he plays bishop h5 which would be a
really instructive mistake
there's a hidden trap here bishop h5
would be an attempt to defend the f7
pawn
while keeping the queen and the rook
connected on the eighth rank
so after bishop h5
we don't want to take on b7 because then
black's knight comes out to d7 and
that's why keeping the queen on d it's a
good idea
what should we do after bishop h5
yeah vomton got it well queen b4 is a
notation or a queen b5 check lpdo
anytime the king's in the center i've
mentioned this many times
this diagonal in particular a4 e8
should be at the top of your mind
anytime there's an undefended piece like
that you can exploit it bishop b6 so we
actually will
almost transpose into bishop takes f7
now what should we do well first order
of business obviously we should take the
bishop
now we should decide which pawn to take
and i'll i'll put it this way both queen
takes b7 and queen takes c6 are good
i'm not sure off the top of my head
which is better
so let's queen take c6 is more forcing
so let's calculate queen takes e6 check
so if black blocks with the bishop or
the knight
we have an incredibly powerful move
there
who can tell me what it is so let's
calculate queen takes e6 check bishop e7
we have a move that looks like a
knockout
no not bishop g5 bishop g5 doesn't
actually attack anything on e7 because
the e7 square
is the most well defended 95
whoa 50 subs by x nina oh my god
oh my god the move is 95 so distracting
and what about queen e7
which is probably nope it should be
seven
i mean just look at this thank you xenia
for the subs 95 how do i see this move
well
you just gotta spot the tandem of the
queen and the knight right you you have
to be aware of what the queen and the
knight are capable of
and queen f7 is now a massive threat
knight h6
just play bishop takes h6 and the game
is over
and that's also very important detail
the fact that we the fact that we can
take any piece that appears on h6
stop distracting me xenia
thanks for the 50. you're
insane okay
let's not take our foot off the gas
pedal what should we do now
well now it's obvious
bishop takes g7 yeah we should just take
the free pawn
yeah bishop takes g7 simply
and it's i mean we're just taking
everything here
yeah it's all pretty easy
ten dollar donation from forensic life
coach probably about three thousand
dollars for the youtube content here's
the down payment thank you
down payment are accepted save your 3
000 for a real down payment
given the real estate market right now
um okay what should we do now well we've
got a choice a basic choice between
taking the queen and then taking the
rook and being up a rook
but if we want to try to win faster
we can also give a check on c8 and
potentially take on b7
um i like the ambitious approach i i
don't i feel like the end game is going
to take us a while to win
so why don't we give a nice little check
on c8
i mean
bishop d8
now
we actually have a choice of which rook
we want to capture we can take f8 or we
can take b7 and trap the other rook in
the corner
the funny thing is queen takes b7
might be a actually no it isn't less
accurate
i mean i i don't even know what to do we
have let's just take this rook let's
take this rook
and then if queen takes e5 we'll play
queen takes b7
right because this
queen takes b7 isn't really going
anywhere
right but but the rook on f8
could have moved to g8 that's how i
decided which to take
now we play queen takes b7 notice that
it also stops queen before check not
that it would be dangerous we could
always cover with the knight
but now we're winning the second rook
just brutalizing black here
it's only been 14 moves if you can
believe that
okay
queen c1 check
is a threat right not automatically
grabbing the rook now is queen c1
winning for black is that mate no
even if you were to blunder quincy one
you would still be winning after king e2
but why allow it
now you might start panicking and say
well the knight's also hanging that's
not good
but
understand the bigger picture here right
i like to refer to these these kinds of
moments as
sensing the bigger picture what do i
mean by that well we're already up a
rook we're about to win another one
is our priority to contort ourselves to
save the knight or to make sure that our
king is safe so that we never have to
worry about any counterplay again
yeah knight d3 is possible but the the
sort of russian school of chess move is
to just castle queen castle king side
yeah knight t3 in this particular
instance is fine but knight t3 there's
actually queen c6 so 93 is worse than
castling
knight 23 queen c6 saves the rook of
course completely winning but
the classy move here is to castle
does that make sense queen takes c5
queen takes a8
now queen c6 is impossible because the
knight covers that square and we win
so when you're up like a ton of material
and you're trying to convert try to come
up with what your top priorities are
here it's it's clear that our priority
is to get our king to safety and the
rest is going to be easy
the rest is going to be very easy
our second priority is to complete our
development we're not going to win this
game unless we actually get our rooks
into the game and we're not going to get
our rooks into the game unless we get
our night out
so let's just get our knight he's going
to play bishop c7 i can guarantee you
or resign
again not falling asleep on the threats
what's the best way to defend against
that mate threat
what what move has the most oomph
no
no
knight f3 is fine but somehow i like f4
i don't know push your pawns right
steamroll steamroll black with these
pawns e5 f5 we're gonna use these pawns
to win quickly
now you might say well
how do i know that it's okay to weaken
the king
but black has no pieces left again
just like you can
take your clothes off once in a while if
you live alone
it's like
black's king can take its clothes off
and there's no black pieces to punish
him this d5 okay that was
slightly over the top but
see now you're not going to forget now
you're not going to forget the concept
that i want to illustrate
you i like chad pretending like you all
y'all put your pants on within five
minutes of waking up
in in cove at times
okay so
now let's get this knight into the
center with 94.
that comment was definitely directed at
brandon
okay i feel like i've backed myself into
a corner here so let's uh
kindly
uh exit gracefully exit this topic
am i wearing pants right now no i never
wear pants while streaming clearly
you guys know i do i mean i i do get up
occasionally while i'm streaming
okay we're threatening knight f6 jack
i'm not even commenting on this just
because everything is easy rook ae1
knight f6 f5 choose your you know choose
your win
let's go knight f6 chunk
king e7 knight d5 is a fork
king f8
now i know it may sound like words word
that this is a moot point and it is but
i want to give you a sense of like how i
convert these positions
in the most effective possible way the
move that i like here is actually queen
back to d5
centralize the queen yeah just get the
queen into the center now you're
threatening a check on g8 and then a
fork on d5
probably black is going to go d2 here if
i had to guess yeah queen a7 is fine
knight d7 is fine
but this wins the queen
everything is winning so any question of
the forum why not this or why not that
probably the answer is that it's
perfectly good enough
oh queenie it was made in one yeah
okay but if you if you have made in one
win the queen
it's like the old joke look for better
if you have made in one look for better
thank you stephen gray for the five okay
well that was a pretty one-sided game
obviously
but
the point that i want to make early as
we start to look at it is that thank you
jay numes thank you everybody for the
subs
the point that i want to make here is
that
look how easy this game was just because
we knew
like two moves of theory
that's why when you hit like 1800
if you're a london player or you play
sidelines you should cont you should
consider
at least attempting to learn the main
lines
i feel like there's been this trend in
the last few years where
pardon my french but
everybody shits on main lines
you know main lines are dumb they're not
worth studying
there's a reason they're the main lines
to begin with and the reason is that
if your opponent doesn't know them you
can actually basically just win the game
out of the opening consistently
so
it's worth taking a stab at it so yeah
e3 is the second move you can also start
with knight f3
queen a4 check is not good because the
point here is not just to win the pawn
back you also have to develop your
pieces while you're doing it you don't
want to do it with your queen yeah a
channel demonetized
you don't want to do it with your queen
uh it's it's a move like queen a4 check
has been played before
even by some gm's but it's definitely
not the most critical
amon thank you knight f3 is the most
popular mode knight f3 knight f6
and now e3 this is the positional
version knight c3 is not that good
and then e6 you might be aware of like
this line and now black has
the main move is c5
and you get this type of position you
very often get iqp structure out of
queen's gamma decline queensland
accepted but after cded you already have
an isolated queen pond structure
um
is there a problem with knight c3 yeah
so people asking about knight c3 here
it is a move
it is it is definitely a move
um
hmm i'm not sure off the top of my head
why it's like not played more
often i want to say
you have a knight f6 i guess you can
play knight f3
yeah i'm not sure i'd have to consult
like a source on this me i know e5 is
the move oh maybe it is e5 maybe it is
e5 yeah thank you for letting me know i
see i don't know this is like out of my
league it is e5
e5 is a very very typical idea
in uh these types of positions
you're using the fact that you have um
you're using the fact that you have an
extra pawn to basically use that pawn as
a bargaining chip and if d takes c5
happens
this trait is obviously undesirable for
white because you've got to take either
with the knight of the king both are
awkward and clearly this position is not
impressive for why you also have a weak
pawn on e5
by the way the same concept is applied
in the blackmart dmr gambit
after uh e4 d takes e4 f3
who can tell me on the basis of what we
just discussed
what is a very good and solid move here
for black
yeah there is a difference and i'll
explain in a second
yeah e5 right same concept just e5 de
queen d1 you get the king into the
center
and you just get a great position so
just re file that idea away like pushing
the ear c pawn
and using the queen trade as a
bargaining chip like as a tool to
discourage your opponent from taking
pride in this in the c3 sicilian
there is also a line like this
so in the c3 sicilian there is a line
where black actually takes and goes e5
now this isn't great
um but the point is after d e black just
plays queen d1 and knight c6
and i actually lost the game i know i'm
spending a while on this but i really
want to hammer home this point
these types of end games are very
unpleasant
and i did lose a game like this many
years ago and it sort of stuck with me
that even up upon these positions are
often not worth going for this is a game
from when i was 1700.
yeah so basically um this isn't anything
super impressive or anything just just
want to hammer home the point
so
yeah so my opponent played this line and
the correct move for white here is
actually knight c3 but i didn't
know any better so i was like oh free
pawn right
but
this is just bad like bishop g4 and
already i started to regret it black
gets this huge initiative castles and
bishop b4
and eventually i mean my opponent didn't
play perfectly but
eventually he won the pawn back
and even this position is very
unpleasant because white's king has
absolutely no safe square
inter mezzo
and then he went a pawn
and then he won the game
so i used to lose to this guy told her
it's an old russian dude many many times
before i actually beat him so hopefully
that makes sense
back to the game
so one other subtlety to be aware of
one other subtlety to be aware of is the
difference between going knight f3 first
and going e3 so the the main difference
that e3 allows an extra option but on
the other hand is also more flexible for
white so if black goes knight f6
um then after bishop c4
well okay i'll put it this way after
knight f3 you give black certain other
options like a6
which are eliminated if you play e3 but
on the other hand e3 allows this uh
topical move e5 once again that's why
people most commonly play knight f3 to
prevent d5 and this is a line like this
e3 e5 is a very theoretical line
with uh you know
chances for both sides you get this iqp
structure and you can investigate this
if you want
but e4 is the line that you play if you
really want to play ambitiously no i be
i beat totors of later when i was like
2000. i actually beat him in a very nice
game no i mean victor's i think he's
still alive he's he's probably in his
80s
um
so e5
is one of the main moves this this is a
good move
there are four or five reputable
lines against d4
if you want me to i can show the game
how did i beat totoro okay fine
so i only been once i was already 2000
but it was a very satisfying game
because i'd lost to him three times by
then
so this was all in the mechanics
institute like every game i played
against him was in the mechanics
institute
and this is already 2006.
okay so this time he goes e5
oh he passed away oh recently well no he
was probably over 90.
i i hadn't seen him in in years he was
such a nice guy too
so
he was kind of like an informal mentor
you know as i was growing up playing the
mechanics
so it was a rye lopez i have a better
position
i'll verify though i'm not i'm not sure
i trust that information
that's edge
i don't know if i should be showing my
like win you know
okay so in this position i found a
really nice idea
bishop b3
d4 and bishop takes f7 check
this was nice
he'd probably want me to show
because he told me when he beat me in
1720s he told my dad like
give him two years he'll be beating the
crap out of me so
um and of course i was like no i'm not
and the idea is king f7 knight g5 check
king g8 of king g7 there's a fork
king g8 queen b3
and it's over
king moves either way knight f7 is a
fork so he had to go
to the side and i took the rook and i
win everything
so
that's how i finally beat him
yeah rip
and sag he was yeah and he he played
like well into his 80s which i find to
be so
impressive
anyways
back to the game
so after ed bishop g4
the main moves here are knight c6
and bishop b4 check
this should be for check
after bishop g4 it's already almost over
queen b3
bishop b6 we trade queen takes c6 now
bishop e7 loses on the spot
had black played queen e7 though we have
a check on c this is my idea this is a
very important check
queen ca check
that's it i mean it's not it queen d8
queen b7 97 saves the rook
but we take another pawn
and come on we're up two pawns the king
has already moved this is lost
so
yeah so that's that's about it i mean
after 95 i guess black can also move the
queen away
what do we do what does white do here
who can tell me what how what is the
most effective
way to convert the advantage here
routinian thank you for the radar i am
about to finish but i still appreciate
it
thank you david there's a very pretty
line here
so it's it's queen f7 check
then queen g7
so you're threatening to take the rook
and you're threatening a fork
so black and tri queen f6
what should white do now what's a pretty
move that wins the game
not queen g yeah queen eight eight
seven and we win so pretty
straightforward game the rest we don't
really have to talk about everything
else is very simple
that's about it ladies and gentlemen
promised myself to go to bed by two
so thank you everybody much appreciated
thank you for the um give her the
support all right guys have a good night
thanks for hanging out
see you guys soon
later
[Music]